Here we have our two charges - a positive and a negative.
And let's assume they're equal in size so the positive charge
is as positive as the negative charge is negative.
Now might be a good time to introduce the Coulomb, which is the unit of charge.
We could say that this is a charge of +1 Coulomb and this is a charge of -1 Coulomb.
Now let's make things interesting.
Let's say that another charge, a third mystery charge arrives on the scene.
I'm not going to tell you if this is a positive or a negative charge.
I want to know what direction is the net force on this mystery charge.
Is it up? Is it down? Maybe there's no force at all.
Or maybe it depends on whether this mystery charge is positive or negative?
Think about this one and give me your best guess. I warn you it is a bit tricky.